this all happened around six o'clock
tonight on king's way on the south side
of town
authorities telling us someone started
firing shots from a home
when deputies arrived the suspect
started shooting at them
forcing them to use their vehicles as
shields they stayed like that for over
an hour
until the situation was able to be
handled
we train for this our intention is
always to end the situation without
having to take somebody's life we were
able to slow things down because
we were in a position of tactical
advantage to be safe
and our officers we kept them in place
while we coordinated resources
and were able to get them in place until
a time where he stopped firing weapons
the captain went on to say the suspect
has a history of such incidents
including a possible incident here in
las vegas
almost 20 years ago we do want to point
out that no one was injured in the
incident
and at no point did any deputy discharge
a weapon
really the best possible ending to a
very intense situation